they have so much power these people get
away we're working within the parameters
of the law to achieve an objective it's
a legal fox hunting way too early for
the hunt today to me that's a little bit
[ __ ] up and reversed what you're doing
is interfering with a legitimate
activity
[Music]
[Music]
oh you don't even our real-life Huntsman
now we don't kill all forces that way I
don't know what is your side of the
story so you tell a venules side of the
story you come with me you come with me
no like you've got your masters and
you've got this high rank and people who
do this and who do that and then you
just got a pack of dogs running around
like it does this crazy crazy lupus so
many elements to it is so difficult
that's what I said to consider our novel
opportunist I'd love to go into it with
you know
it's still traumatizes me today it never
leaves you
and I'm only seeing these two cups run
out of a woodland and the mother ran
behind him on this hill and she's turned
to face the hounds and as they come she
just cold curled down and they ripped it
to pieces and it was it was horrific and
you know that's needed 15 years ago and
I still I still yeah it still hurts that
the first time I saw a fox died
we nothing special we just everyday
people who it is sick and tired of these
people getting away with it and we put
ourselves every weekend our liberty an
alive on the line to try and save these
animals from these these Mehadrin
Psychopaths and it yeah fox hunting has
been illegal since 2004 with the
introduction of the hunting ax hunting
with dogs became illegal in England and
Wales it's also illegal in Scotland so
there's an understanding that foxes are
a problem they don't have a natural
predator therefore we are allowed to
control them so they're we're allowed to
control them in Scotland it's not we're
allowed to use dogs hounds to flush them
from cover but they must be short
[Applause]
to marry Gontier of what are you
thinking remember did they applaud it -
killed over here was vampiric inkless
it's not even it's not back by a
distance so I can probably say they're
going to be hunting within this this
triangle
over that way okay what do you guys when
they head off to the kennels done if
this was a game of chess we've got the
first move we've got a volunteer just
putting up two moves before they even
make one that we know where they're
gonna be and not just that we know we're
gonna be we've got a rough idea we're
looking at a map where they're probably
gonna hunt these are people in the
hunting community
these are hunters themselves hunters
from other hunts who don't want us
anywhere near and would rather us go and
pester their neighbor and hunt them go
and ruin their day of hunting you see
how I feel we might come in my head for
the four minutes of seeing a fox being
ripped to pieces it would change
people's shoes I think everyone is
horrendous down there in Wales
as I said before complete feeling of
freedom it's just on parallel but
anything else this adrenaline religious
or adrenaline junkies never you know you
know for a deployed across country and
you go you voted for us that's not the
only reason that you can you can
possibly come up with as to why people
still maintain this practice of hunting
foxes with dogs and on the back of a
horse is because they enjoy fox hunting
they enjoy chasing a fox and seeing it
killed at the end of it there's no other
reason there's no logical reason why you
would do this you look back at the
origins of fox control fox hunting it's
all about pest control you know even the
life bartlett 16th century it's about
pest control
there's no sporting element in forks
control and certainly not in scotland
because you know açelya are our foxes
are flushed and short
they tell you things
good morning are we too early for the
hunt today oh you don't have to go we
would we've talked we invited by a
friend of the riders to come to marigold
for the hunt
okay thank you very much yeah yeah okay
they're still in the kennels actually
that wouldn't suggest that um they're
not going to the jet so that would
probably also lead to say we passed
there's a couple of riders at the meet
and all the way past to be asked if if
we were to early for the hunt and the
woman's face was like oh I don't know
what you want about but familiar from a
reaction it was like she knew she went
meant to speak to us so what is a good
chance that they're probably at marigold
but just wait and see who else appears
well the 2002 Act requires certain
things under law it doesn't require the
falx impact the master of the huntsman
to record and report to police Scotland
but they do so so if anybody had any
concern if they phoned up please
Scotland that our radio where the
activity is ongoing they really have
direct communication with the master or
the Huntsman they can within minutes of
the tortures to be at that location and
then to view that individual but what we
have is as highly edited subjective
narrative splash across mainstream TV
suggesting illegal hunting when
investigated it turns out that it's not
it's compliant legislation but either
that either they either have a lack of
understanding of the ayat or they're
being deliberate and they're their
attempt to influence politics if you go
on the far ends and we'll go see what's
in there okay
but this is brilliant if their pants of
this fantastic the only reason that the
conditions are perfect the only reason
they would have counsel is because it's
in you like them we would be we've let
ourselves down on here there's no
there's no other one then there's no one
else here yeah
that the weather today is perfect
hunting conditions and if they're not
going out because they've seen saps and
have called the police that would
suggest that they don't want to go out
hunting today because we're here that
makes a question if they are acting at
all like they keep telling us why
wouldn't they come out today if they if
they have plans to do illegal activities
up here they wouldn't want us to be here
we are here if they are acting in within
the law like they always make out they
are then there's no reason they
shouldn't be and should be hunting today
principally for pest control there have
been flushed and shot they're not being
traditionally hunted as the ones where
which was your the main tenant of the
act a 2002 I wish to prevent the chase
and they killed by hands in Scotland
there is no restriction on the number of
dogs that they can use but League
footage has shown quite a few times and
recently with the JED forest
a trial and conviction that actually
there are very very few incidences or
flushing two guns very rarely are there
guns on site in in our observations
we've seen you know hundreds of hours of
footage taken from the aunty side where
they were all of you thinks my far and
conclude an outcome without really
understanding the mechanics the huns
continued to operate as they would pre
ban and they use these mechanisms to
deceive the public and the police as to
what they're actually doing
this is series their little village next
to where the five fox hounds are based
so I'm just going to go over the map
just now what we need to do is figure
out where we're going to be basing
ourselves at that Junction their place
in that way anything come to you might
seem come down anything comes up just on
the right hand side now
when you get convicted and stuff has
ever put you off doing what you're doing
I just how does my resolve
I wonder happened the three convictions
forgot last couple of years have all
been nonsense and it may not be one of
them
drive the six miles out holding a mat at
the same time which if I can do that be
a hell of a skill but I wasn't high
witnesses to say it wasn't again you
know they have so much power these
people get away with whatever they want
they get away with things here so he's
broke he's gone it's okay oh oh yeah I
see that you cannot break your gun like
that are they acting above the law
yeah of course they are there's nothing
that anybody with a dispassionate view
of this would say would say otherwise
if the police enforced law knew how to
enforce or whoever this laws been in
place maybe 15 years in Scotland and the
police submitted to us last year they
have no idea how to enforce the law and
if they were breaking the law the police
would land continue to break the law
they wouldn't stop it
[Music]
so what we've got going on now in front
of us is to fight fox hounds wagon
assuming they've got hounds on board so
we are gonna go and see which way they
go so we can get our idea when it me is
going to be see where series is if you
go north east towards north on the road
back in the same direction so we have
the fun games each Fox on package hunt
is a club really a society
they don't charge for the service but
get income from other other areas such
as charging people to follow on on
horseback there will be a generalized
committee and the weave masters so the
people who have got a direct connection
with other farmers so they make those
connections in terms of permissions so
where do you want us to be how often do
you want us to come in to visit where is
your stock it's important that you're
delivering a service but not out to run
roughshod over the countryside there has
to be permission from the landowner but
the Masters responsibility yeah an eye
signals pads we written the meat
what do you think we need to figure out
soon what we're going to do those that
much time so this is the five homes and
they have been observed to what we
strongly believe great in the north of
fall so today we're going to be here to
make sure they stay within the law we
strongly suspect they're going to either
move off this way or this way so we'll
just have to be ready to react and where
they're gonna go
we've got lights just Direction wall
quickly we are now going to be making up
this little joke here you see down on
the left hand side behind its farm
building you can see the homesman you
can also see him get ready today so what
we want to do is get off people before
he does they still is nothing home comes
way he won't be happy about it here to
make him happy with him to chop the
paper you might have you when you were
out at the hunter another horn he'll
know all of his homes by name so he can
control them by voice or by horn or his
physical presence so he'll be direct in
their homes we've run the back
a person fighting their Wars towards him
is what we was cool to win for in your
whip friends job is to make sure they
keep the hounds together and the hounds
don't go charging off because we do have
a road out there and you'll see today
that the hounds will go across roads and
put their cells and producers in danger
people are commenting on horses pay for
it they pay a subscription my job is to
deal with the farmers like speak to
farmers become friendly with the farmers
make sure they've got access to the
ground build fences basic organized the
day or the day for them in return
in goes to ground it'll just cover
resent so just make sure the hounds
don't market to ground where he's gone
see the stones filled with oil so when
they run a free their paws they excrete
you got the scent glands and they'll do
kind of persuade if they run and leave
leave down at Senate and if you can get
those hounds to lose that trailer I
don't have to start again and can't pick
up again you've affected to save the Fox
they respond to the whip and then lift
their head and if you get their head off
the scent then that will stop them
momentarily give the Fox enough time to
get away you know this one holes down in
the bottom there so if you choose the
proper time Wednesday the Fox could will
run down one of those holes well aware
of that
but we're at the moment we've got a high
ground we've got great visibility
there's hunt saboteurs everywhere at the
moment behind this some over there
there's four over that way we got
ourselves on the top here so it's
basically what's gonna hold the high
ground we've got a really good advantage
place and then we'll take it from here
see where they go when they will react
to whatever they do if you believe that
foxes were a pest and they have to be
controlled
could you think of a more economical
method of controlling a pest than
getting a load of people on horseback
a pack of hands and rampaging across the
country to chase a single Fox it just
makes no sense whichever way you look at
it okay they've gone away from us
they're going away from us towards mundi
farm west okay brilliant
that's great they're gonna that's not
legal but it's really really
irresponsible of the Huntsman with these
hounds and horses and the people riding
with a hammer from this I think there's
kids out riding one today so he's
putting everyone in danger as well as
the road users just so we can go and try
and kill something so to me that's a
little bit [ __ ] up into first the
Honda half are left to me in a different
direction to where we were we're hoping
us because we regarded a woodland in the
wildlife in it they have been come
across this field here and the hunter
actually came on to the a9 to a main
road so they're putting the hounds road
uses the horses and the children rider
would hunt at risk so it's quite
ridiculous that they allowed to disrupt
traffic in the way they have today so
we're now going to try and see if we can
get eyes on again
where'd it being drawn us to go around
for everyone and trying to head them off
okay we're going to go on and then we're
going to try and get ahead of them the
guns its massive bit area up here so we
need to jump ahead and try and catch
house no point follow him there move it
off already gone off that way we've gone
over along I'm gonna try and carve off
okay
here's my comment down there
[Music]
well the 2002 act changed the practice
fundamentally prior to then Fox aims
could find and and and pursue a fox for
a considerable distance healthy fit
foxes avoid homes they get away to
survive unfit wounded your diseased
forties are caught and killed so it's
very much contributing to the animal
welfare species level but know every Fox
has flushed has to be short so
regardless to age or infirmity or health
the Fox is short so that's that tarses
it is detrimental Huntsman coming down
here is what his hands going through
here there's no gum another back there
we just walked through there's non stop
there so to pursue anything now I'd be
tell you leaving the other side of the
woodland here
there is no Cummins out there if you
pick up I'll be careful like our men
want to catch illegally Honda now do we
they say you put a gun in a field at the
end of some woodland would be the wrong
thing to do a fork should run towards
the edge of cover would sense if not
smell or see someone and not break cover
it would probably turn back into the
woodland so we have our gun station
where we know the Fox will run
so by stationing guns within the
woodlands we can shoot the Fox safely as
it's coming through the woodlands not
put them out in the field for some form
of pantomime
you're gonna come in some ways fun hop
team instead have you got any comments
on my spots one answer fox hunting sir
have you any comments on my supportive
well Chilean men can work with or
without a full tank pack so it's a job
really for when a focus goes to ground
takes responsibility for flushing the
forks underground walking above ground
from rocks you're interfering can you
please remove yourself from here to move
now you please need to remove yourself
because what you're doing is interfering
with a legitimate activity I have to
make you aware that what you're doing is
aggravated trespass I always say we're
not here to clothe you and it's your
account
Mike I'm is safe
now you've stopped me doing what I'm
here to do okay
the way works up in Scotland yes you see
forces in these cover goods positioned
all over the place to do that and is it
easy to for it not to be legal is it
really hard to make sure everything's in
place when the Hunts going I've been up
in a house and I sitting there just like
you know how the guns I have to be ready
for flushing is it easy for hunters be
in a position where the guns are not in
place and they've already started to
draw so that you've maintained contact
emotion okay so the guns generally go
ahead of the pack because you've got
generalised thought process where you're
going you know and historically foxes we
use the same areas so you know pretty
well where you're going to draw so you
can direct the guns to go on ahead of
you and if you view some of the footage
as I'm sure you've seen on online you'll
often see a chord back up to moving
around and that's the guns been deployed
in situation
give any comment okay your partner legal
foxhunt in that case as well and there's
one of the masters you need to rein them
in I will go to all documents on these
video cameras here do you want to say
anything to the cameras okay
the early part of the season
young hones will be introduced to the
pack they will run with a full pack of
hounds and they will at that time of
year engage younger foxes there's no
attempt to to utilize that time to
somehow habitual eyes a 14-2 to chase a
fault it's natural they are only
following following instincts and if
those Fox hands don't look as if they're
going to take to the activity or they
are lagging behind then they just shot
and then disposed off we've seen
evidence of the kill of the Fox being
covered up because they don't want it to
be known that they are actually killing
foxes they'll let the dogs feed on it
because they starve the dogs before a
fox hunt so that they are hungry and
that they are looking for an animal
center that that's whether you know
they're out there for the kill
patrina very well they live outdoors
near the communities so they'll have
their own hierarchal pack places that
where they have a routine health check
they are all chipped maker chapters they
are only used within Fox and banks you
can acquire a fox and from a pack if
you're not raised at Fox Empire
I'm safe but it's not loaded at the
stake but it's said yes it was Odin
since you turned up what making safe
triumphant within the law and then
there's no good
[Music]
the hill this is why your generation of
people which service you now have
generation people against it you still
have a generation of people that are so
deeply invested into it it's like it's
in our pertinence in our DNA to want to
support this finger to continue a keep
it going and the tradition aspect would
be for me making sure that our system
people think that because this is a
tradition that has been carried out over
many many years hundreds of years that
it should be something that we protects
well we used to stick children our
chimneys because we thought that was a
good idea just because something's
traditional doesn't mean to say that it
should be continued and the same goes
for hunting you know it belongs in the
19th century it should stay there we're
in 21st century and we should just move
on the myths around pest control are
exactly that complete myth boxes are a
self-regulating population if anything
research shows the population pop that
the population of foxes has gone down
since the hunting ban and not going up I
think it's important that people
understand that the law allows the
control of wild mammals this is not
something that's done without
consideration this is not something
that's done without legislation we're
working within the parameters of the law
to achieve an objective
bounce bounce bounce from spin offense
but that as a space where socks are also
going so that's good to be aware of
these tracks we're gonna Pete runs to
make sure the paths covered red-handed
breaking the law and we've been on their
tail ever since and we've got taps
following around now they're very
unhappy they're trying to get away from
us and that's because they know we're
doing a good job we're doing exactly
what we're here to do and have to stop
them to break the laws and vote on
wildlife can you come into the middle
bit to cover it where the guys are at
the moment that sound you can hear his
hounds and cry which means these house
are picked up on a fox
there is no gunman anywhere around here
so if they continue to chase this box
it's completely illegal
reason why we position ourselves to all
you have if you look across the line
we've formed basically a human shield
across so they are picking up on a fox
there's there is a fox around we need to
now establish where the Fox is coming
through our way so the idea of us
haven't split like this if it does go
through us then we're in position then
to move in and close the gaps where the
hounds my coming through and this make
sure you send them back it's a really
tense moment because it could be a fox
and anywhere around us right now
[Applause]
[Music]
a fox kill can take any amount of time
it can be pretty instant but more often
than not it's a process that takes place
over quite a few minutes I mean that's
not that's not including the chase
itself which can go on for hours and the
Burns report suggested that whether a
fox is killed at the end of it or not
the impact is severe on its well-being
you effectively terrorizing an animal
for many hours there's no need for it
don't need to do it it achieves nothing
by doing it so why do it I simply don't
take the death of an animal lately and
none of my colleagues do either you know
we're out to do a job when you do the
most humane where you can't to to kill a
fox humanely swiftly it has to dive
relatively quickly within a few seconds
and again the Barnes inquiry and Lord
born amis inquiry concluded the diet
currently happens they don't have any
evidence to suggest that foxes are and
nearly we've been abused by the Fox nine
Paxson's call well we were coming up
this bit I'm a heard and I was like here
and the hunt and apparently now here
it's kind of just quickly checking your
map sister gives a rough ideas Ally
where we are what do you know what their
end well
same difference with oh really okay
[Music]
the opportunity to get ahead yeah this
is a Adam Galpin Terry man of the pie
Spock sounds but as you saw earlier on
when there was a team in the woods he
came over and unloaded they took out a
shotgun and made that a live poem even
though he saw people in there he got his
gun ready and that's the kind of
happiness people like him use and then
they say you're in the line of fire when
actually he's brought a gun to where you
are now as a member the public have the
right to be there
are you access right and this is some of
their tricks that they use especially
Adam here and he does this quite a lot
and I have to make you aware what you're
doing is aggravated trespass Kevin knows
this he knows that he should have to
breach your firearms difficut now that
matters that one of licenses making it
safe it's not a firearm what is it then
shotgun well it's the fire no they're
two different things we really need
educating you know nothing do you as you
need to do need a license to own a
shotgun certificate okay and does that
say you can pull it out when it's
members of public art and in low do we
fire we load it with can you tell it
some bullets or do you put it in he's
the lowest of the low in the hunt for
Terry man Chavez
we stayed with the hunt all day we have
people all around the countryside
picking off to hunt every time they ran
they ran into Morse ABS - Morse ABS
- Morse ABS and it was just a really
really successful day and they ended up
going at home at half past one which is
for a fox I'm pathetic when you consider
some hunts down to four five six o'clock
in the evening so it's not about
education it's of a direct pest control
at a given time so it starts an autumn
and goes right through the year till no
total early March when lambing starts an
analyst they've achieved the objective
they've got the population down to a
sustainable level that won't impact on
livestock are enlisting parts national
polling that we conduct over many many
years suggests that 85 percent of the
public are against fox hunting 85
percent say they don't want for
something to come back nationally if you
took that out and just said the rural
communities it comes out as 81 percent
there's no difference between rural and
urban communities in this everybody
thinks this is a waste of time we
shouldn't be doing this and it's in our
practice it's an outdated practice
[Applause]
crazy
to the window though yeah we're at the
moment in waiting to pick up any horse
boxes going to the fox hunt today we
know they're very elusive we just pulled
up and a horse boxer just pulled up too
so that it's good for us it shows that
they're on today there is a horse in
Elkins here just at the front so once
they pull out we will intercept them and
then we will hopefully find them to just
basically gone into a farm building
there's no other activity there other
horses or horse boxes that so they
hunter said no they were being followed
so we if they are we've to hum then they
have just ducked and dived out the way
they don't want to lead them to the to
the hump that's what horse boxes should
do I like the Fife where they just
happily lead you straight to what if he
is so we're going to go down there's a
team down and now check in around the
areas see if they can find the hump
we'll go down and help and check in here
as I haven't down but when we get there
and then what we'll do is we'll go to
the kennel check the kennels and then
wait for any further Intel about the
bearing show cookie base took a chance
to get rid of that today but this case
is really interesting that the evidence
taken to the crown was that there was no
guns present
so the Liga in school sports had filmed
activity from over 600 metres away and
it's told police gone there was no guns
present yet clearly on the video you can
see guns the chap who shot the Fox was a
retired wildlife trained policeman the
sheriff accepted that what he said was
that the gunman should have been closer
to the den where the Fox was bolted from
know the rationale was that they had
bolted that den season after season
after season I knew that the fabric and
structure it's an a quarry
it's too dangerous to shoot towards it
for fear of ricochet
so the Fox is allowed to move away from
it and then was short but sheriff
Patterson decided that there should have
been a gunman force make it a proper
crime and make it a cry
that really hits people hard if you
perpetrate this criminal act you're
going to be punished for it and you're
going to be punished for it in a
meaningful way and I think that will
have two impacts it will have the impact
of people less likely to do it if they
know they're going to go to prison and
secondly it makes it something more
worthwhile for the police to actually go
and pursue so what we need to happen now
especially from the the SMP the Scottish
government is now that they've shown
that they are breaking the law we need
it to be a complete ban it is just no
other way forward for me can all still
still there as well so we don't believe
taken out today for whatever reason we
don't know what is not going out and
that's a victory yeah a total victory if
they're not on site if these guys are
not out in the countryside hunting foxes
its complete victory not just fast but
for the animals out there they terrorize
we know that the the hunts actually
actively try to encourage foxes to to
exist and you know we'll keep them
captive so that they have a ready-made
source or foxes that they can then go
and hunt this has got absolutely nothing
to do with pest control it's got
absolutely nothing to do with anything
other than having a good time chasing a
fox across the field so Fox hunts will
say that this is a form of pest control
in the countryside but there's so many
different ways that they could do this
more efficiently when you get maybe one
or two people go out lamp in the
shooting of Fox yeah I don't agree with
that I think it's awful but it's more
fishing and having a huntsman Masters
Riders whip her in 30 to 40 hounds loads
of supports and cars and on foot that's
not that's not pest control that's a big
show they're putting on this is their
tradition they're trying to keep alive
five watch your feet watch your feet so
let's go
we know what they're doing is nothing
but just to cover turn to their six
story I've gotten out and murder in the
Fox I mean they call our sport but in a
sport both sides have to agree to take
part at the Fox doesn't and the Fox
being so heavily outnumbered by the
massive people and horses and Hounds
chasing it with the merger was an honest
question
didn't defied opinion whatsoever brainy
when my father came into me now if you
have folks population vivillon Easter
they will read read read
they will never naturally without food
here Islamic saved constantly have to
keep this evening the top of the filter
Fox population down
very few livestock are killed by foxes
there isn't a huge amount of data and a
huge amount of research that's up to
date but the last set of research that
was done in around suggested the animal
kills
Cindy many some way too many to say but
it's not quick from what I've seen
personally you never seen never seen as
far as concern
absolutely mark my words and what you
gonna do is you gonna try them on the
ground you're gonna have hit the rock
myself even similar people to make their
will have five or six hands no makeup on
weekend and they'll just it they want me
to worry about whether they're in the
Lord or not
so what you're doing is you're hoping in
a kind of worms you know wanna be on it
one another no we are the figureheads we
are those final you can say us when were
an open organization
it's been discussed more times done some
significant events in our history one of
two Wars included and we can't get a
conclusive outcome we accept absolutely
and need to control wildlife but there's
a perception that mounted fox control
equates a modified enjoyment social
event as opposed to a pest control
service now absolutely without
contradiction what we do in Scotland is
pest control
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you